hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to resident evil village
also known as resident evil 8 also known
as the game that i have been looking
forward to
because of its incredible gameplay
graphics detail and the level of quality
that you can expect from whoever the
hell made this game
i can't wait to play this because i love
the resident evil series
and in the past i've played it before
therefore it would be expected that i
would play this one
there's no other reasons besides that
no other reasons at all so without
further a do we're gonna get into this
um well you know
ah you know i'm just gonna go standard i
usually like to play the i
every other resident evil game i've
played again um and i usually do those
on the higher difficulty levels just
because once i get my feel for the game
i really want the challenge
uh but for this experience you know i'm
just gonna just gonna play
standard oh long ago
a young girl went with her mother to
pick berries for her father
who was hard at work but the forest
greeted them with a dark cold silence
the bushes empty yet determined to find
the berries
the rascal broke free from mother's
grasp and vanished into the trees
mothers worried cries faded fast as the
girl ran on
over vine and under branch and into the
forest deep
feeling strange eyes upon her the girl
recalled mother's scary bedtime tales
and her throat became bone dry
then the pat lord appeared he greeted
her warmly
and bit his own wing come child quench
your thirst he said
so she drank the thick dark blood and
smiled with joy
passing through the graveyard menacing
storm clouds
loomed and the air turned bitingly cold
the girl was shivering in her thin
clothes then a dark weaver appeared
and with a click of his fingers crafted
mist
into a beautiful dress come child
warm yourself he coaxed so she clothed
herself
and smiled with joy
across waters deep and ominous she went
hoping a boat she found would carry her
home
but hunger's grip tightened and her
heart grew heavy
then the fish king appeared and offered
one of his
many fins come child eat your fill
so the girl ate and smiled with joy once
more
continuing on she soon entered the
forest
dark where is she going then an iron
steed appeared
bearing a beautiful golden gear
the creature said nothing as the girl
approached and snatched
what she thought was another gift the
horse grew
angry and summoned the other monsters
terror filled the girl's heart as the
wild wind rose around the beast
suddenly a witch appeared dark
yet regal
oh and that's that and then the girl
died because she was
just constantly wandering into oh the
more you took she snarled
you read that to a baby
in a blink the girl was trapped inside a
mirror
there she's asleep
yes with the creepy story she's only six
months old
that's what i'm saying woman at the
store said it was traditional
a local tale yeah that doesn't mean it's
good for a baby
rose doesn't seem to mind okay because
she doesn't understand it
thank god we moved here so that she
wouldn't have to deal with any of that
remember
there's nothing wrong with my memory
you're just being paranoid it's not
never mind i'm sorry yeah but i'm not
paranoid i'm just cautious
then go cautiously take your daughter to
bed
okay sure i'm sure this is gonna go
great you know
given that this is a resident evil game
some don't seem right about this baby
you know i'm not going to lie about this
because that
don't seem right if you don't remember
this is actually continuing from the
story of resident evil
7 so i believe the ming want to remember
it
i can't blame her uh remember what the
horrible events of that family
in the woods in the swamp nothing
nothing
i don't put her down wow you know i do
always appreciate the detail put into
these games like
even though the majority of it is
obviously non-interactable man
we sure love plants in this place
honestly actually it's pretty cool
i like the amount of detail put into it
baby wants some fud
you want some food you want some pickles
yams i don't know salsa wine baby wants
some wine
oh big zoom
our taste in music's definitely improved
over the years
[Music]
i don't know who the pale boys are um
man we drink a lot of wine
in this house i'll go put the baby down
to bed wherever the hell the baby goes
upstairs i think possibly there's
probably some secrets that i could find
right off the bat but
you know i'm not gonna dig too deep
wife whatever your name is i know i'm
ethan
winters once things warm up we can go
for a walk
yeah yeah cold of winter seems to have
lasted unnaturally
hey baby shut up shut up baby the ghosts
you don't understand it's like i said to
your mom
that book's too scary for you yeah well
you know the
the moral of the story is um there's
nothing free in life
so don't assume there will be
am i hearing baby wanna shower
baby want a nice refreshing shower
shower for the baby
okay and i do not know how to take care
of a baby baby you want a pill
mia's medication she's been a strict
regimen ever since the incident
yeah the horrible fungus that infects
your brain
i'm assuming that's the same mia from
the other game as well
almost there honey almost there
oh this looks well okay it doesn't look
bad
but in any resident evil game any like
childhood home room or anything is never
good
why did they cover the mirror up to save
resources or to save me from looking at
myself
rose is closed for tomorrow will we ever
reach
tomorrow oh wait no it's it's
the parent's room oh okay weird uh
uh i do not like the look of this baby
uh there's a preview picture that we saw
of like the very large man
uh baby kind of looks like that but it
might just be the baby fat who knows
me and i had another fight i
accidentally mentioned what happened
three years ago and she blew up at me
we finally settled down in our new life
in europe and can bring rose up properly
but i still feel like a part of me is
trapped in that hell hole back in
louisiana
i know mia doesn't like to talk about it
but can we really just forget everything
and pretend it didn't happen
shouldn't we face what happened out
there so we can live our lives with rose
without it hanging over our heads
i mean what do you mean by face do you
mean like face
like face it off again go back to lose
we lose
never mind i'm not gonna bother we owe
her that much at least i know mia knows
this too
she wouldn't have exploded like that at
the hospital if she didn't care at the
hospital
in the hospital weird how that
weird how that desktop screenshot looks
like the developers just angled the
camera like this and took a picture
i mean i might too rosemary winters uh
height weight screenings all no issues
results for additional fungal pathogen
tests will be provided by the bsaa
so those are inconclusive
rose is fine rose is fine
rose want a monkey with bigger monkey
well hi there little rose
that's horribly cringy ethan winters mr
winters
gun survivalist it's not paranoia if
they're really out to get you
yeah you know what you're right about
that
oh look at that why is ethan's face all
blocked out
why is ethan's face all blocked out
i don't like it
no i don't i don't feel right no i don't
feel right
i wish i could stay like this forever
well
it's a lot of poop to deal with but you
do you man
most times just keep your mother waiting
she's scary when she's angry
yeah you know what i mean yeah most most
first-time parents
usually want sweetheart phase to end as
soon as possible don't you worry
i'll be right downstairs skip fully
won't let those weird
never mind no photo fairy tale monsters
get you
i got an achievement for photographer i
didn't i didn't do anything
okay whatever all right honey
how's dinner coming along
smells good babe
oh there you are okay i thought for a
second maybe oh no
no no is she okay sleeping like uh
well like a baby look at the liquid
physics that's amazing it smells good
what's that oh hands off mister it's
choba de la gum
hand right in the soup we've gone full
native haven't you
local wine too but if you're gonna keep
sulking all
evening maybe you shouldn't have any
you really have to stop worrying
it's just finding you in louisiana the
pregnancy
chris moving us here military training
it all happened so fast
you know well at least we're all
together
you me rose
now everything's going seriously think
we can just forget about what happened
in louisiana
it happened so long ago i just i don't
understand why you are so
yeah get down
oh god
oh hey bud chris what the hell
sorry ethan no
what why
man chris looks different he looked
different before now he looks really
different
all those steroids finally worn off go
move or maybe he
doubled up who knows my baby
my baby this seems like kind of a dick
move the hell you doing with my daughter
package secured sir package how'd you
know her middle name
i said get your hands off her ethan no
okay well he said no
can't do anything
[Music]
i'm assuming mia is fine
and i'm assuming rose is not fine
because i mean if mia is still feeling
the residual effects and by that i mean
total infection
of this fungal virus but she's normal
now
probably means that the baby uh ain't
so normal
she'll see us next week
hey now think positively all right
we talked about this i know
we hardly talk about anything else
i keep telling you it's not rose that
i'm worried about
well then what are you worried about
look
she's gonna be fine i just know it what
else matters
we matter ethan you
matter you just remember me what are you
talking about
is there something you're not telling me
come on talk to me
damn it i have to take this yeah this is
definitely more important than this
very urgent conversation
yeah that's definitely a priority eve in
winters
why is this why does that make me
uncomfortable oh it's just a baby
oh where am i now
i have to take this work is calling
chris
buddy babe thanks for shooting the wife
what are you talking about where's chris
redfield
and rose
you really just gotta ask who is this i
think that if it was a secure channel
you would stop talking and then
hang up immediately what the hell
happened here
yeah well nothing good usually nothing
good happens in resident evil games
uh well looks like this dude is all dead
uh eliminate target recover body secure
rosemary winters and ethan winters
okay so eliminate target i don't know if
you eliminated the target move the two
winters
winters to sight see for further
investigation at least two transport
officers to accompany them
yeah well that didn't see did the baby
break out
did the baby hulk out boom right out of
the back door
i'm thinking the baby i think the baby
blew up i think the baby blew up all
fungally
a great fungal explosion
all right well i can't wait to go up and
find someplace warm
hopefully like a castle or something you
know oh that's kind of creepy
yeah hopefully like a castle with like a
warm welcome
like a a welcome that feels like a great
big hug
you know just a smothering embrace of a
place
just kind of like a something very like
large you know with with tall ceilings
and big doorways
huge knockers on the doors you know
really good
welcoming sight
hey is that the thundering footsteps of
one of those
mountain giants i've heard about that
i've heard so much about and respect
i've heard and respect about oh oh
i can crouch i'm going to be doing a lot
of that
well it wouldn't be a resident evil game
if i didn't hurt myself stupidly right
off the bat
all right i'm up i'm moving i'm mobile
i'm gonna ignore that oh yeah i'ma
ignore that
definitely a whole lot of nothing
yep whole lot of nothing weird growls in
the forest afternoon
well that's a bunch of dead crows
oh hey uh oh ah
hmm this is uh normal um
very normal i miss you
just gonna just gonna crouch
just gonna crouch you know i was caught
out of crouch this is a lot of crows
that are dead
i don't excuse me
thank you i think it just decided to be
quiet now
definitely nothing else happened to it
come back here are we playing tag
oh man i didn't know i was interrupting
a game of hide and seek
i guess i'm it uh
okay cool river sure
sure is sure is
dark at this night
and this looks vaguely familiar this
looks a lot like the intro to
resident evil 7. i'm just going to bars
my way in here i never asked for
permission to enter a home
although this doesn't look like the
castle i was looking for so to be
perfectly honest i'm i'm
very disappointed i'm like exceptionally
disappointed
this will come in handy or not
or absolutely nothing in there was
useful
i love fiddling with random crap as soon
as i enter someone else's home
i mean i got such a warm welcome last
time blood's a good sign
that's a good sign maybe i'll take it
it's fine it's fine hide in the closet
inside the closet
in the closet yep totally fine okay
hey i'm not robbing you
i am looking through all your stuff but
i just like to observe
how tall are you whoever you are this is
curiosity ah good
mysterious basements i'm so hey
fox i'm so glad that mysterious
basements are
a very important design feature in every
home i go into
banana okay
this is good yeah this is good
i'm sorry i'm sorry
i know how far down you'll have to stoop
over to pick that up
i don't want to burden you
looks like uh this game of hide-and-seek
is coming to a conclusion
hello peek-a-boo
well that was hardly scary would be a
shame if something behind me was scary
so i am i am kind of questioning why i
came out
did someone very tall just arrive home
did someone's rather wide upper body
area
break the door frame on the way in was
that the sound of a very warm
embrace coming to welcome me
is that what that was oh uh
what wrote ah
what lovely art you've made
i love it i love it
also checking to see if recording is
going smoothly
it is this is good good recording
okay um well that's cool and all that
but also
garlic no vampires here
and i do know that this is kind of a
whole werewolf versus vampire thing
which is
dope not sure how it relates to the
whole
did i see someone not as tall as i was
expecting run over there
did i see that did i see that also how
did
i thought i was nevermind hey
i'm not nearly strong enough to let i'll
just crawl
apparently i'll i'll i'm crawling now
heavy box
what did all this oh only something
about
nine foot six ah nah this is a
disappointingly small
silhouette it does look like someone
just sideways who should rather wrote on
just went
straight through the wall but i'm uh
just
oh it's day
uh uh it's
it's day now um
oh no a barrel's in my way okay well
i'll go
i'll go it is dramatic the difference of
being in first person versus like third
person with
resident evil two and three and this
obviously the story
here is very far removed from that i did
love those remakes but resident evil 7
having that first person perspective and
just like
remembering all of the like promotional
stuff
and the demo that came out when like re7
was being teased in just that house it
was
like just such a dramatic shift i i i
really do love it
like it is something fascinating the way
that they're able to
completely change the experience
that looks like a lovely castle i love
the buttresses
and the crenellations who is crinkling
oh
your friends are all dead you might want
to run away
spooky okay ah
so what you're saying is fly to the cat
well your loss i've heard there are
great things
grand things at this castle like about
two incredibly
grandiose things waiting for
the brave to appreciate the art of
oh no they didn't just get the crows
still warm huh well if this is like most
survival movies i'm supposed to crawl
inside its corpse and uh
stay warm that way but no i'm
i'm not gonna do that
yeah i'll go in hey what's up anybody
mind me breaking in
anybody gonna stop me
pig pig
pig oh yellow well i know yellow
needs some kind of other item yeah sure
uh-huh good thing they also have marked
all their important things with yellow
tape
blood great good
oh handcuffs even better
double extra good oh outhouse
well oh it's occupied dammit
if there was another door to this
building let me just quickly
check that one i don't think that
they're going to give me anything
particularly important this
hi windmill okay
hello maybe maybe they're out yeah
maybe maybe maybe they'd left in such a
hurry that they splattered their stew
oh that looks like a punch that looks
like a big pouch
someone there yeah that looks oh that
looks like someone got
pouched holy crap someone got pounced
oh my god someone got freaking
pounced hey there's that painting again
all right so i'm not gonna bother with
it
peekaboo hide and seek champion 2021
ah they're good they are good
not gonna lie this year it might not be
such a
cinch for me to win this
uh ye
here is the he who oh boy oh no those
aren't crows
you know from a distance i thought
them's was crows turns out them's not
crows
thems is uh goats well parts of goats
half well i think total they add up to
about one goat
what oh yeah if i couldn't read that
thanks for the subtitles i guess okay
there's a light on over there that
usually means place i'm supposed to go
if my gamer instincts are kicking into
maximum gear
which they are locked due to missing
homeowner
these other missing homeowners don't
seem to be locking their homes
i don't know who's doing that as a favor
that looks fun probably some part of
some collectible or something
yellow ladder all right well we got to
the village park boom i'm here
someone want to tell me what my grand
mission is where's my baby
knife where's my baby
someone better give me my baby well
i'm glad they gave this to me i
certainly won't have to use this is this
going to be explosives
i just remember that ethan winters must
die i did love
all of the dlc and like bonus rounds in
resident evil 7 that was something that
was missing from resident evil 2 and 3
it's like all the different bonus things
especially three like i feel like three
was a digital hurried
get punched they might have gotten
punched this is a hard blanket a really
tough blanket
oh my god holy [ __ ] why would i open it
like that
who sent you nobody there was an
accident down the road
what's going on
[Applause]
good thing he's a bad shot oh no
they're coming who is what the hell was
that
do you have a gun what please tell me
you have a gun
no why would i well i'm about to i think
i really do think i'm about to have a
gun
oh i've taken it i'll take it
okay
hey are you listening hey
well there he go goodbye friend
goodbye european friend with the
mysterious american accent wow that is
hope that's not your blood well
you know they really did the two-pronged
attack
is my blood going to shoot upwards
dead party well you don't know that
wait there's more
do you need to say all this out loud is
this necessary yeah
them some deads maybe that old guy was
uh not so good
excuse me sir
pardon me you look a lot like that other
guy christ
yeah what the hell is wrong with this
place
probably the same thing that's wrong
with everybody
[Music]
hi over there i see you squiggling
what you doing
well that's a bad start
am i infected now oh my god
holy crap
[Applause]
hey only one person in this game is
supposed to be able to do that to me
[Applause]
okay well good thing i got this boom oh
my oh
[ __ ] you kind of quick bang
okay well you got more life in you a
little more pep in your step
all right that took a lot of bullets
good thing my hand is missing
maybe double tap just in case maybe a
little
slough slightly slip slivly slowly
all right well i am bleeding profusely
maybe i shouldn't have come back in
maybe coming back in was a bad idea
let me see if this guy got any more
maybe coming back in was a good idea
i don't think there's anything else all
right
well yellow shovel there's something
here
there's something secret damn it they
can't just put a yellow shovel like that
i'm always gonna think there's something
all right bolt cutters
always gonna have the bolt cutters on oh
i don't like how slow that opened i'm
not gonna go there just yet there's
gotta be something else here
some bullets or something
cam i got kim
got a whole lot of chem
[Music]
i got herb and i got chem my two friends
in this
sordid affair of death and destruction
all right is that all their woos
anything in the pot
all right let's yonder
hello sure do love cricks
that's fine that's totally fine
i'm going to try to kill the next one
with a knife even though it's probably
going to end up with me
like taking a lot of damage i just want
to get used to the idea of killing
things with knives because
i'm going to have to do it when i run
out of ammo which is going to be soon
i'm coming in there bam boom bam
oh i'll do this
no i'm not locked in here with you you
you in with me i'm
here we're here together
hello okay well you're done
come at me [ __ ] that's a lot of blood
you want some stab
soup delivery
we're fine startled you didn't i
you [ __ ] come here get some stab
you want some stab it's some stab whoa
what did you deliver that for me
like a cat thinking that i can't hunt
for myself did you feed me
probably not well that don't sound good
where where hello stop
stop let's get back get back
no no where why am i here
oh hello wow you are real you all are
really like
okay can i like probably not worth it
probably not worth it definitely not
worth it
is this worth it this is not worth it
it's gotta be a way out
oh hey bud okay hang on
yeah get back get back get back man
jeez what do we do
uh oh hey button oh my god when did you
get here
okay i got a guard okay i got a guard on
that this is why i'm practicing why i'm
practicing okay let's try guard
regard i'm guarded
okay there's really no okay i'm gonna
restore my health
where did i get goof where did i get
goose fluid
okay that still happens he had that in
his neck
i exploded his head i took all the scrap
out they're robots
that's the secret truth behind all this
they is actually robots
over yeah when they see me explode their
friend's head i
i think they all were dissuaded from
their course of action
hello what if there
are any survivors out there come to my
to louisa's house near the fields uh-huh
all right okay well i guess it's all
done now i guess i'm free to go
that's what i'm gonna do i'm leaving
yeah
good thing i used my healthy hand to be
able to do that
what's back here
a boot hello
someone in there okay whatever i don't
know why i have a
proclivity to go off the beaten path
but i do love exploring
i hear something i don't know if you
guys can hear it my keen
senses you know tuned from here
bang hey bud you got someone
oh no oh i didn't know that oh i didn't
know that's that's what this was
oh no oh no they have weapons
they have weapons
i'll take that oh yes i'll take that
all right buddy looks like it's time for
me to kick ass and kick ass
and hide i'm a [ __ ] i'm very cowardly
i got gunpowder i'm gonna blow it in
your ears and then blow your brains
right out
create attack oh sure
i know what i'm seeing i'm so stealthy
am i is anything actually coming after
me
i mean they sure sound close
was that a safe was it safe i don't have
a combination for that
no it was probably a cabin
no one's here no one's here yeah no one
no one
you can't see me you can't see me
i am there's no end to them there's no
end to them
well there's an end to them all right
um coming in to get anything
supply splash yes i love it i love it i
love it i love it i love it i love it i
love it i love it i love it i'm up i'm
up i'm up i'm out i'm out
i'm up i hope there's no werewolves
waiting for me up here
i've made it arrows was that air oh
uh okay where do i go where am i going
where am i going where am i going why is
there arrows shooting
okay i'm just uh oh i don't know i don't
know where do i go
i'm going is that explody barrel
is that an explody barrel hey bud
take some of that oh oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] ocean
ocean ocean
i got i got lay
where do we go what do i do get out of
my way
was i supposed to do something else here
i probably was i'm probably just very
dumb
oh it's glody barrel
there had to have been something else
right i'm just very stupid
okay hold on hold on to your horses your
horses
you know there was nothing my gamer
instincts tell me there was nothing
i'm just gonna go this way down the road
i can't go that way
that's all locked up
oh my god oh my god
oh my god okay well this is uh bad
for me um holy [ __ ]
okay this is this clearly a dead end
oh oh no i'm in trouble
okay let's go shoddy gun time okay but
how's this
and uh some of this you like okay all
right good
now we got that settled oh my god
oh yeah yeah this is bad oh this is open
now
this was always open oh god
now really out a lot of owl
okay so clearly not that way this way
this way is locked why is everything
locked where am i supposed to go
i don't know am i stupid
oh that one got me yeah the first one
really missed but the second one
definitely swung me do i have a
whoa what did i just do what did i what
what am i doing
i don't have any healies oh my god
i'm so doomed
i legitimately have no idea where i'm
supposed to go i
truly do not know i am in pain
oh there i go
oh hey buddy
was this all supposed to happen
fine decoration man that's
that's some good stuff
you gonna do a sweet jump slam on my
skull
oh i thought you were going to do a
sweet jump straw
[Applause]
you know you're tall but
uh
quite tall enough you know not tall
enough for me to really respect you
you know the respect you got a lot of
power i respect some of that but not as
much as you might think i might respect
that
surprisingly i don't find myself
respecting you very much yeah hands
still
borked hand is what some professionals
might call
borked
oh perfect hey santa
huh no you're not santa
what yeah wait
can't wait for me wait for me pal
okay so it was all it was all scripted i
was supposed to not be able to know
where i was supposed to go
not liking this you are so funny
you are so funny hey what's up ma'am
in life and in death uh-huh we give
glory great uh hello
you shouldn't be out here it's not safe
what the hell hey can you hear me
it's you the child's father
child hey wait do you mean rose is she
here
rose rose yes
she is in great danger since mother
miranda brought her to the village we
have fallen into
darkness hmm what are you talking about
the monsters
the castle bell herald's danger
they're coming oh yeah it wasn't
dangerous up until this exactly where's
rose
who's mother miranda the bell tolls for
us
all they're coming again
[Laughter]
yeah i see how this is funny
hey wow nice meeting you nice meeting
you ma'am nice meeting you okay the
yellow is really throwing me off
okay hey i'm not threatening boom
sure don't slam indoors like i wish i
did
um
so uh where's the rest of this village
an easy to pick lock
so you say but uh define easy and define
pick define lock
and define everything else where am i
going
that is kind of the crazy thing about
these games is like it looks chaotic so
it is a bit difficult sometimes to
navigate but usually there's a lot of
sense to it oh
except for that last part well i mean
that last part was logical in that it
was supposed to be confusing
because i wasn't actually supposed to go
anywhere so it did create a very nice
sense of panic as i wandered around
trying to do anything
and i obviously wasted a lot of bullets
that i didn't need to waste because i
could have just rolled over and died
okay everything's locked from the other
side it's amazing how they planned this
perfectly
oh well probably need a winch of some
kind
i got ammo
hello nope okay open inventory
items can be crafted in the crafting
menu change menus with q and e
okay i can make first aid i could make
gunpowder
or i can make handgun ammo that's good
um i'm gonna make med
sun and then i'm going to
use it i look like i'm in bad shape
right
medicine that'll grow my fingers right
back
right back all right so
i'm going to end this episode here uh
i've got a meeting that i got to get to
but expect a lot more of this very soon
we didn't quite uh reach the splendor of
the mansion
or the castle rather it's much bigger
than a mansion
way bigger way bigger grand heights
soaring towers huge
tracks of land really beautiful stuff
uh respectable stuff that i respect so
thank you everybody so much for watching
uh look forward to more of this very
soon check out the other resident evil
playthroughs that i have linked in the
description or they're probably in the
suggested videos over there
and as always i'll see you
in the next video bye-bye
[Music]
you